if we go out there with everything that
we've got
we can make this happen my first
question for you
is you know is it your vocals in the
entire series is it a mix of your vocals
and selena's
what can you tell us about that it is
selena as it should be
i think that's what the fans want you
know they want to hear selena singing
that's what i want as a fan
and i'm just i'm so grateful that we
were getting to use her voice and her
music
you obviously had a lip sync the entire
series right yeah so
i you know i still worked with a vocal
coach um
there's some singing that i do like in
scenes that's
me but every piece of music or
performance or
show is selena so i still wanted to work
with a vocal coach i still in fact like
recorded some songs i think it was
really helpful in like preparation
uh and really helped me like understand
how
it like fits in your mouth and you know
when we did performances
um i was even though i'm technically
lip syncing or we're not using my vocals
i'm still
singing 100 because i want it to look
like i'm singing i want it to
feel correct you know and um
and so i think i think that payoff is
gonna be nice
sadie how wild that you're in the selena
movie as
her friend i'm sure you've been getting
this question all day now you're in the
spirit
as her mom i need you to spill the tea
how does the series a movie
compare for you mentally emotionally as
an actor
well when i did the movie i was looking
at it through
a 20-year-old's perspective you know and
it was discovering who selena was for
the first time and
in her story for the first time um and
this time
i get the you know the gift to come back
into this project and see it from a
whole
different perspective i mean who gets
that
you know it's like for an actress and
for a person it's like
it's amazing um and so in many ways it
was almost
like like looking into my
looking into my childhood through my
mom's perspective
you know because i i lived similar
things in the nine
in the 80s and 90s and i was just like
god this is so great you know
it was amazing it really was one thing
that really shocked me because i'm
i was a fan of selena you know growing
up i loved the movie
but was the lengths that los dinos and
southern pearl went through just to make
it
like making the lights out of peach cans
getting their name dropped
i was curious for the both of you what
was the most shocking thing that you
learned about
your what your character went through in
real life um
you know for for me it was the humble
beginnings
you know i'm from south texas i'm
born the same year as selena we're
separated by four months
uh i grew up with this story in my in my
lifetime the number of times i would
jump into my father's truck and
he'd have it on a tejano music station
and there would be a selena song i
i can't even count um but uh but
so you think you know a story because
you've grown up around it and then you
read the scripts and it's like
wow um and for me it was like the
absolute humble beginnings and the
struggle that they had to endure
to get to where they got to for me i
would i want to say uh
the the writing the musical writing that
ab had to
uh that he did for selena and those
dinos um
you know abraham challenged him a lot uh
you know to better better the music and
when you come up with a hit
you know you got to come up with another
one and keep going and there's just no
stopping and uh
i was i was uh you know i was one of the
things that
that was really interesting to me was
how abe
you know he wrote him on the floor he
wrote you know all these iconic selena
songs and i didn't know that
going into the project so once i started
learning more about ab
and uh his influence and all the music
um it's it's really really cool if you
stand around and wait for what you want
you're gonna be waiting your whole life
you will have to go and get it
i can tell you like as a huge fan of
selena a huge fan of the movie i just
felt like your
portrayal of her is so accurate i mean
just everything how long and how much
did you rehearse and prep for this role
like
walk us through that whole thing when
did you find out you got it what did you
do
that means a lot to me so thank you um i
i yeah i just i wanted to do such a good
job so badly i just
am so grateful i'm so excited that we're
telling her story again i'm excited that
we're telling an elongated version of
her story we're seeing more of her
we're seeing you know the hard work that
came before the legend and i think
that's so important and i think that's
going to
make you know the second season where we
see her
more as like the star we know today i
think it's going to mean so much more to
people because
they've seen the hard work and the
changes that she went through as a um
as a young adult and a kid trying to
like find
her how she wanted to be perceived on
stage i think that's really fascinating
but i
i found out um you know about this
project i feel like two years ago and
the audition process was really long and
i'm kind of grateful that it was because
it nearly acted as prepped for the
for the show right by the time i found
out that i was going to be
playing her it was i think a week
a week or 10 days between the day i
found out until the first day of set
so there was um
i had already started you know being a
big selena fan i felt like i had my
research of selena so i had a great base
but that base
definitely was those few years when she
was at her peak when she was
in her early 20s you know so
um i had to just go a lot farther in
time and do a deeper dive and
social media was super helpful like all
the like selena fan accounts on on
instagram ended up being like a really
great
resource for me and for like a lot of
the cast um
and luckily her family was on board so
we have like a more
intimate i think um insight to who
she was when she was younger and how she
became the selena that we know today
yeah oh instagram coming through how do
you think you know jlo
and christian's embodiment of selena how
do they differ
or are they similar i think that they
were perfect
for each project um for the movie
we we got to know who this who this
superstar singer performer was you know
and jennifer
is an amazing dancer and she has like
this
presence and and this you know strength
um and energy and so i think she she was
perfect it was
perfect casting for for the film
and but for our series i think that
christian has this beautiful
vulnerability
um in this like inner strength and for
what we were covering
in the series i think that it was
important that
that the act and i i'm not speaking for
anyone this is just my own personal
experience i think that it was important
for
theatrics to naturally have that element
so then when you saw her in those
intimate scenes
it could come and live through just
naturally and
and organically um and so that's why i
think they were both
perfectly cast for each one 100 agree
it's like you can
feel the warmth um no emmy you are just
such an incredible suspect first of all
i don't even know how you can pull off
the 80s hairstyle so well it is almost
like
unfair watching it anybody watching this
you feel like you're watching a real
family on screen honestly
how did you did you guys have any
bonding activities like how did you
create this really tight-knit
you know quinta nia family on screen
specifically you know
all five of us we are such true strong
um connected professionals that um
christian was still wrapping up the
walking dead so we had dinner the four
of us
um and it was just kismet to to
you know have a bring these to the four
of us there bonding as actors as
individuals as latinos
latinas and as a family and then
um you know i'll never forget our first
scene as a family at
family dinner and christian being there
it wasn't right sadie it was like an
orchestra because we had to time when we
passed the tortillas when she was in my
salad bowl
that's your salad bowl
i had this personal thing with this
salad bowl that
i was like don't touch my salad
because i became a joke with everybody
and now it became a joke and like it
just
gave the family vibes of like laughing
together and then like
passing the baton and doing it while
telling the story
staying connected and and it just really
helped and that was early on in the
series so it really helped
show not only are we connected as
characters but as actors and
and that this all matters to us and we
want to do a good job and it's wonderful
that we all were
on the same page together with that well
you guys nailed it you did do a good job
everyone's going to want to know did you
guys shoot part two yet
and when are we going to be able to yeah
yes we finished
two weeks ago what can you tell us about
part two like what are we going to see
in that one
[Laughter]
music concerts relationships love
habits children are an adult yeah
[Music]
you know for the both of you i want to
know how you embodied the characters
like ricardo did you
watch edward james olmos's performance
interviews did you
get to sit down with the real abraham um
and then after for you gabrielle you
know
did you actually play guitar what was
your experience with music beforehand
but we'll start with ricardo
uh so i've never seen the movie what
i've never seen the movie no um and when
i found out that i got this role
i purposefully did not watch the movie
because i did not want it to inform the
decisions that i was going to make
and how i was going to approach this
character so i watched a bunch of
interviews
of of abraham that they had online
youtube whatnot
and as i started watching them i started
seeing things that were indicative of my
father and my theos
that are all from south texas and so i
just started doing my research that way
and grabbing a little bit from
from there and a little bit from here
and and uh i mean
i've been raised around these men for 40
some odd years of my life you know so uh
i
i don't want to say that it was easy by
any stretch of the imagination
i had a lot of work to do and i made
sure to do the work because
i didn't want to think that it was easy
does that make sense yeah
uh for me yeah i didn't i didn't play
any any uh
musical instruments at all so when i got
to uh
when i started the project and we
started uh rehearsing the musical stuff
you know i picked up the bass and
a b plays the bass and at first i didn't
even know how to hold the
the bass you know it was strange to me
it was so weird and then it you know
and then as as you know as practice we
kept practicing and practicing and uh
i got you know start to get better at it
and they practiced a lot
they practiced a lot they did amazing
jobs i'm sorry i had to interrupt real
quick
they practiced a lot and they did
amazing jobs appreciated
um yeah it was fun you know and and like
the dancing too you know ab dances as
well so
yeah he's got that tejano bob you nailed
that
we call it the quintanilla dance
and uh yeah it's fun it's great you know
and and so so being able to do that
uh playing the instrument and dance was
uh was was hard it was it was hard but
it was a lot of fun
it's funny selena's always she's always
represented you know
she publicly went through the paradox
that we go through as latinx
you know people growing up in america
which is i'm not
in her case mexican enough or i'm not
american enough
i know you were born in california but
you're mexican so did you
struggle with that personally growing up
and and did you channel that into your
performance
a lot and i think that's why you know i
had such admiration for selena i think
it's why a lot of people do because
there's a huge community of
mexican-american people
and that is one of our icons and you
know she
was such a pioneer and broke down such
barriers for for us and
and and women and people like me so i
was just so excited being
mexican-american that i got to
betray her that i got to go to mexico
where my grandparents are from
and i got to live there and work there
and just be surrounded by my culture and
my language and my people and
yeah it's an experience i'll never
forget
[Applause]
selena
you